[موسيقى]
لطالما شكلت معرفه الاخبار هاجسا لدى
الناس حول العالم فاستخدموا الوسائل
الاعلاميه المختلفه وطوروها عبر الازمنه
الى ان ظهرت الصحف ما دعا الى جمعه هذه
الانباء وتقديمها في طبق واحد وهي المهمه
التي حملتها على عتيقها وكاله الانباء
فكيف نشات وما قصتها تعود نشات وكاله
الانباء الى عشرينيات القرن التاسع عشر
حيث تم تشكيل اول شكل لوكاله انباء معروف
في مدينه نيويورك حيث عملت جمعيه الصحف
الصباحيه على جمع التقارير الوارده من
اوروبا بشكل دوري هذه الفكره بدات
بالانتشار تدريجيا فظهرت وكاله انباء
محليه اخرى وبحلول عام
1856 تم تنظيم جمعيه الاخبار العامه التي
ضمت العديد من الصحف المهمه في مدينه
نيويورك وهي المنظمه انبثقت عنها وكاله
نيويورك اسوشيه بريس في سبعينيات القرن ال
19 لتكون اول وكاله انباء تعاونيه لصحف
محليه كانت نيويورك السوشيه بريس تبيع
نسخا الى الصحف اليوميه بجميع انحاء
البلاد قبل ان تنشا يونايتد برس عام
1882 لتقوم بالمهمه ذاتها
بعد عشر سنوات تم دمج هذه المنظمات ولكن
في نفس العام تاسست وكاله منافسه وهي
السوشيات كريس في نيويورك ثم لحقت اوروبا
حيث قام ثلاث وكالات دوليه مهمه وكالتها
باس الفرنسيه ووكاله رويترز
الالمانيه المعروفه باسم وكاله وولف
بحلول عام
1866 ظهرت الوكالات الوطنيه في العديد من
البلدان الاوروبيه وكانت تقوم بتغطيه
الاخبار وبيعها محليا
تطورت وكاله الانباء منها ما اعيده تاسيسه
كوكاله السوشيت بريس التي اصبحت تعرف
برمزي اي بي في عام 1900 ومنها ما ظهر
بشكل جديد حيث اصبحت رابطه الصحافه
المتحده التي كانت تسمى اليونايتد برس
يوبي شركه تابعه لصحفي سكريبت كما ظهرت
وكاله خاصه حيث اسس وليم راندولف هارت
خدمه الاخبار الدوليه اي ان اس في عام
1906 وجعلها متاحه لاوراق الناشرين
الاخرين بالاضافه الى خدمه الحصول على
ابحاثه الخاصه
لكنها سرعان من ضمت لي يوبي لتشكيل
اليونايتد فاست انترناشونال يو بي اي في
ظل نجاحها تعرضت الوكالات المحليه في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لمضايقات حكوميه حيث منعت الوكاله في عام
1915 من تقييد استخدام فيها لمجموعات
معينه لكن المحكمه العليا الغت القرار في
عام
على الجانب الشرقي من العالم وفي عام
1956 تاسست اول وكاله انباء عربيه هي
وكاله انباء الشرق الاوسط كشركه مساهمه
المصريه لدور صحف الاهرام واخبار اليوم
والهلال والتحرير
توال تاسيس المزيد من وكالات الانباء حول
العالم وفي المنطقه العربيه حيث تم تاسيس
اتحاد وكالات الانباء فانا وتدشينه فعليا
في عام
19740 وكانت وكاله الانباء المؤسسه
للاتحاديه
التونسيه الجزائريه السعوديه السوريه
العراقيه الفلسطينيه اللبنانيه الليبيه
المغربيه واليمانيه
مع ثوره الانترنت قامت العديد من الوكالات
بتخفيض عدد العاملين والتره لتكيف مع
التغيرات في نشر الصحفي والبث الالكتروني
ولكن رغم التغيرات لم تنتهي الحاجه لهذه
الوكالات التي طورت من عملها واصبحت تقدم
الى جانب الاخبار خدمات الصور والفيديو
الحديثه والمؤرشفه
[موسيقى]